we are booting this stuff out of Florida
right now that is what DeSantis is doing
this very week uh Joe Contreras I'm with
the Guardian newspaper and the
Washington monthly magazine
among the areas you identified that's
like left of the left right
can I ask my question no no I mean you
can but I just I I've seen it's uh it's
interesting
among the areas you identified for
academic reform in your January 31st
press conference where the diversity
equity and inclusion programs and
policies often known as Dei for short in
effect at Florida's public universities
and colleges yet Dei was mandated by the
Florida Board of Governors in the fall
of 2020 that was on your watch and most
of the board members were appointed
either by you or your predecessor Rick
Scott why did it take you more than two
years Governor to suddenly decide that
Dei should be abolished in the State
University system thank you so it's a
good question so one it wasn't at my
direction I didn't know what Dei was a
couple years ago as this had taken hold
I mean it sounds innocuous right I
thought maybe diversity of ideas maybe
actually have more than one Viewpoint
well that's not what it is uh what it is
is it's trying to enforce a political
agenda and a political Orthodoxy under
the auspices of administration and and
that is something that that is not in
the best interest of the state it's
incredibly divisive
[Applause]
it's incredibly divisive and I don't
necessarily think anyone that supported
this in the past necessarily had bad
motives but I think if you look to see
how it's worked in practice it's been an
embarrassment to see some of the things
that have come out at Florida State at
some of these universities here it's not
an appropriate use of the administrative
Machinery of a university that oh by the
way subsist on the generosity of the
taxpayers of the State of Florida these
are not private institutions they're
public institutions and we have the
right who are elected and who are
putting people in positions to make sure
that those institutions are serving a
mission that is consistent with the
state's best interests and so as this
has become a problem I ask to get more
information about it we got them
reporting how much money they're
spending on it we introduce legislation
to remedy that and we will be the first
state in these United States to wipe out
Dei in our Pub Public University
Heather I thought there was a nice Maya
culpa there at the beginning by DeSantis
when he said you know I didn't really
know what this was a couple years ago I
thought that diversity meant diversity
of ideas like this thing has crept up on
many many people but you've really been
writing about this for years and years
so you're you must be sort of happy that
people are coming around now and doing
the right thing oh you're way too
generous to me Dave actually I'm furious
that they haven't realized this I'd be
like where have you guys been you know
I'm not the only one I get that I get
that angle too I get that angle I feel
that with something sometimes
but the fact that he's going to do
something about it that's the point yeah
better late than never and you know the
thing that is so disgusting about this
leaving aside the the
overwhelmingly uh biased and and and
fanciful portrayal of the United States
that is the core of Dei ideology the
idea that we are systemically racist now
I'm not going to deny the the white
supremacy and systemic racism of our
past it was horrible and we don't
sufficiently account for it in
conservative discourse in my opinion
nevertheless that is not our reality
today if you'd like more sane takes on
our insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
roundtables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell